- I hear you have a
unique health obsession,
which I think we share.
- Oh, well.
Okay, so, I heard that you maybe,
okay, so I'm really into ginger shots.
- I'm into ginger,
vocalists, I think are
into ginger in general.
- Okay, cool.
Okay, great.
Yeah, no, I feel like
whenever I'm working,
like I have to, like, I have
to take good care of myself.
I try and, and like,
so, like, shots of just
like juiced ginger,
are like, the thing that
get me through everything.
But it's like,
some people think they're really intense
and they are, they're intense.
- They are intense.
(both laughing)
You don't think they're intense?
- Well, I mean, they're kind of intense.
- Oh my God.
I have ginger shots for us
and I want you to do this on camera
cause if you're telling me,
- Okay, I'm not saying
I'm not gonna pull a face.
- Okay, I'm gonna pull
a lot. Thank you, Chris.
- Thank you.
- Okay. Well, cheers.
I don't know if we can
cheers, cause of COVID
- But ooh, cheers. Yeah.
- Cheers.
- Okay, okay, Well, now I'm
gonna try to control my face.
- Me too, but I can already
smell it and my nose hairs,
it's just, they just flew back in my head.
It's gonna be great.
(audience cheering)
(Kelly grunting)
It's afterwards.
- Yeah, no,
I can feel, like I can feel
my eyes getting really watery.
- Yeah, you're doing well, you actor.
- Yeah, I'm like trying
to hold it down, but like,
- I love ginger. I do.
I think every vocalist,
you're a singer too.
So like, I feel like they
would shove that stuff at you
anytime you're like not well.
- Yeah, I mean,
well, this does not make me feel
like I could sing immediately
afterwards though.
- Oh, you know what it does
for me? Like if I'm phlegmy,
that's nice America, sorry,
if I'm feeling a little clumped
and so, no, if I'm feeling
like any kind of like ugh,
- It clears you out.
- Yeah, I can like breathe, yeah.
- Yeah, it does clear you out.
- Yeah.
Currently I'm trying
to fight the head cold
that my daughter has from hell
and I'm like, I'm not getting that, okay?
When you have kids,
they're like Petri dishes of disease
that just walk around your house
and you're like, I just
wanna be well, like.
- You're not making a great
argument for me to have kids.
- You know what?
Hang in there, just enjoy your moment.
No, it is awesome.
And I, you still,
this is how, you know,
you love your children,
even when they're like, oh,
you're like, letting them
lay on you and love on you.
- Aw, see, I wouldn't do that.
- You don't think you would.
You don't think you would, but you would,
even if you have to shoot a
Christmas special the next day,
and you're like, cool.
- Huh, that seems real specific,
is that just a random example?
- Never happened, it was a great day.